you must be the master of your own
Kingdom as long as you enjoy your job
then it's not work if you don't let your
mind get in the way too much then things
seem to sort of run smoothly need
motivation watch a top ten with belief
nation what's up at seven my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have an amazing gift inside you that
I want to see explode out onto the world
so let's get your motivation to attend
and get you believing in you grab a
snack and chew in today's lessons from a
man who went from being dyslexic and
expelled from high school at age 15 to
becoming a filmmaker and creating films
like Sherlock Holmes and snatch
he's Guy Ritchie and here's my take on
his top ten roses success enjoy
all right let's take things off with
rule number one my personal favorite own
the game if you don't own something
you're not the boss you have to take
full responsibility for everything that
you do why be subservient you must be
the master of your own Kingdom philia
makes a lot of sense
you've gotta own that you can't just
walk into things with your eyes half
open you'll walk into things with your
eyes fully open you've got to know what
you're getting into you have to take
possession of your life this is a
thought process that you have to
constantly reaffirm this is exactly that
it's exactly that you drift on this
point right and it is whatever form of
meditation or mantra that you decide to
espouse there needs to be some period in
your day where you remember that there's
a world out there trying to tell you who
you are and there's a world in here
that's trying to tell you who you are
now where'd you want to put your X
because the world outside is very noisy
and very tempting and as all the
razzamatazz as all the Tintin and all
the glitter it's called the toys but
that's because you don't think you're
enough in the first place um you don't
think you're enough in the first place
the whole idea of the world to sell you
stuff is first of all they have to make
you feel bad about yourself less than in
some way and I don't resent this system
by the way it is the system but what's
the expression about don't hate don't
hate the player hate the game don't hate
the game love the game because you're
really amazed Oh own the game accept the
rules and move on into the rules so the
world will try and tell you who you are
and you have to tell yourself who you
are and there's this ongoing battle and
somehow that there needs to be a
reconciliation between the two but in
the end you've got to have all the eggs
in your basket rule number two is
survive failure do I didn't made a film
called swept away which I got
annihilated for
and then I did revolver which I've got
that was the second barrel the first
barrel they took me out with with swept
away and then the second barrel revolver
and it I tell you that was nearly the
end of my career well I was naive a bit
but part the process of about becoming
filmmaker is find out how naive you are
so I mean I love revolver however I do
appreciate its relatively esoteric to
understand and are like swept away so I
don't regret either of them but if you
give the sort of the thing is is who
knows what's the best way to play your
cards I've no idea really you play the
cards that you play and then in the end
you sort of summarize where they played
in the right place and I'd have to say
that they probably were you know the
question is is can can you sustain
confidence while you're taking a kicking
I mean it's love you know know you lose
your confidence and then you start again
and you try and build it up again but
you know that's the human story isn't it
I miss all our stories really rule
number three enjoy your job I don't know
agent actor with you
Carla Henley he was playing it one of
the Vikings yes his big guy
yes he said you know nicest person on
sets and as a director - you're so nice
so how do you keep your cool all the
time when you have all these you know
all these people that you have to tell
it well I've got a lot of people to keep
my cool for me I really I think if he is
long as you enjoy your job then it's not
work so I don't find it particularly
taxing
doing my job and I'm there for you know
we're there for five buns or whatever it
was we're making this movie for so I
think what if you lose your temper once
you like it lose it twice but I'd rather
enjoy my day so I'll make a conscious
effort to have a positive mental
attitude then that picks up momentum you
know
then you just go set set tone and then
you take that time rule number four
realize your own value so there's a
father he has two sons an old son a
younger son and he says to them who
wants to spend their inheritance the
younger says says me that I can't spend
it and the younger son takes all the
dough and he runs off and sniffs coke
off strippers tits for a number of years
until he realizes this is getting pretty
boring an hour in a lot of trouble he
ends up feeding throwing food to pigs
that's his job
and he can't even eat the food that he
gives to the pigs at which point he says
dad will you take me back dad then goes
- they don't meet as somehow happens not
through telephones it just happens
at which point dad goes to the fatted
calf says kill the fatted calf older son
says hold on that what's going on I've
stayed with you since the beginning I've
been loyal to you and I hear the stories
of my younger brother coming back who's
been sniffing coke off strippers tits
for the last habit on those how many
years and you'll prepare to kill the
fatted calf what's the sp that I want
another story this is your eyes son
don't worry about that you take a look
it's a little step to the side you'll
always be with me you're a good boy at
which point it goes out to me the
product of son the wasteful son the
waste or son returns and he says you
were lost and that you found that's the
end of the story it's quite hard to make
sense of that in a literal sense you get
old aunt was a bit unfair me you should
have been kind to the oldest son because
he never ran off and did in a thing but
the essence of the story is that you are
the father you are enough your older son
is your intellect says all don't do this
don't do that he's trying to reconcile
make sense of a prosaic and material
world the youngest son being the wild
feral entity that he is wants to go out
in the world and find out what it's all
about
so in his recklessness
and sense of adventure he finds that he
can't escape himself so he has to return
to himself and at which point he has to
accept who he is
which born the intellect is left out the
equation pretty much is the older
brother because he can't understand the
significance of the journey of the
wasteful brother in the end you have to
leave yourself to understand the value
of yourself you have to lose stuff
before you realize that all the stuff
that you're losing is ephemeral and
transitory it's not yours
you're enough you're always enough but
you've got to somehow prostitute
yourself before you realize your own
value that is the essence of all stories
rule number five always commit fully do
you have moments on the set even as
you've done it three four times now
movies with budgets like this where you
look around and you think back to the
days on lock stock or you look you look
around and say how did lock stock take
me here yes and no it's a funny thing
because zeros some terribly clever
person explained zero zeros because they
ultimately amount to zero and there's
some truth in that
but a creative job is a creative job and
I think you probably spend as much time
on a job that costs ten thousand bucks
as you do on a job that cost ten million
because it's just you commit to the job
or once you've committed to it the
zeroes are irrelevant
and I still find that now so I'm not
intimidated by zeros funnily enough I
probably would be with when it comes to
you know lots of people looking at you
the more people that you're having an
interview in front of becomes
intimidating but money and and films
it's not intimidating rule number six be
your own audience the film I pitched I
think was not the film we ended up with
we have a theory on this that films
pretty much set their own pace at a
certain point my job is to steer the
head of the tiger and after a couple of
weeks you start
the nature of it is and then it tells
you what it's going to be so the first
film you shot was three and a half hours
long and then halfway through it I fell
asleep and I realize how to do some work
was one of my scenes just I had a cliff
note in there and so I realized there's
a bit of work that needed to be done and
inevitably ended up being almost half
that time and because of that it it does
take on an energy but that energy was
really is there to sustain my interest
as much as it is anyone elses I know a
farm entertains then I suspect other
people will be there's nothing worse
than watching a film going oh that's a
good scene but I don't care and there
was a little bit of that that went on
so we truncated it and then bish bash
Bosh wonky donkey we got it working rule
number seven only do things you're
interested in if there is a script
that's unauthorized biopic if there's a
slew of them happening right now is that
something that people can bring as a
director do you bring it to a film i I
can only be get excited by things I can
get excited by it and really I think
that takes place unconsciously so
someone when King Arthur it depends when
they got to catch me but it was King
Arthur and I've just seen a commercial
or some incarnation in this genre you go
all this bits about that quite like and
I think I could do I could do a job on
that so that's really what happens so by
the time this came out a few people have
been told about King Arthur I was a big
fan of King Arthur I saw a couple of
things I went alright it will kill you
that about that and create the tone then
we're off to the races and I think if I
can't do a job with that rule number
eight get your mind out of the way in
sport as soon as you start thinking
about what it is you're doing all goes
tits-up but if you don't let your mind
get in a way too much then things seem
to sort of run smoothly and I think the
creative process is very much like that
initially you need to sort of define
what your creative barriers are gonna be
and then you've just got to forget it
and then intuitively let it roll out so
to speak rule number nine find your
creative process
I was in the theater last night and I
was freaking out a women when he finally
takes that sword does the slow-mo scenes
taken down the bad guys I'm just curious
as a filmmaker how that is filmed what
he looks like when he's shooting it are
you going around him like a 360 how how
do you shoot those moments yeah I mean
that scene particularly was I walked
into that with my eyes blind because I
wasn't really sure exactly what I was
gonna do once he pulled the sword we had
all sorts of different ideas about what
was going to happen but truth was
everything that we'd come up with before
you know it wasn't really working so I
cobbled it together bit by bit which I
do quite a lot of my filmmaking is that
you have an idea of what's gonna work
you're just not sure exactly what's
going to work so you throw enough energy
give it enough information and something
you know stick in the oven and something
once comes out so it was really a sort
of an amalgam ideas and then like I say
you sort of civil and then it really
these things they make themselves my job
is to sort of be a bit of a chef and try
and get the components in the yeah and
increases a lot of metaphors going on
there so okay any real number 10 the
last one before the bonus clip is have
fun what was the funniest kind of moment
on set and I feel like Charlie was the
like the goof on set but like if like
who was more yeah Charlie over to you
I'm not actually the goofball I tend to
be very very earnest and serious about
my process with acting and guy
recognized this very early and I think
it made him quite nervous and he said
alright sunshine that's this whatever
you do in Daniel day-lewis impersonation
or whatever it is you can you can put
that to the side because we have to have
fun every day and if we're having fun
and making each other laugh then the
audience will have fun and we'll be
making them laugh so that was his main
direction to me was just stopped taking
ourselves too seriously and have a bit
of fun the random guy Richie geezer name
generator' is a unique physical
characteristic about yourself and your
dad's first name now I'll give you mine
I get trigger finger
weird wake up with a finger down like
that every morning and my dad's called
Wilson Pickett Rinder will now Charlie
went with 12-inch Billy yeah yeah I know
I bet like four days will and cilia
how's it gonna cause call myself massive
job oh sorry
yeah you went 12 inch Billy's so you
can't but if you can't both at the same
characteristic we are the same frequency
control this rug so you have to have
another one because I've got a plan
alright so big it was your it colleague
boy is perfect all right so let's go so
we go collie eared and then I find my
dad's Christians poor name
no no just his first name Oh Jay John or
Vivian is it John Big John Vivian yes
I've got for a Vivian a koala ba ba
Vivian well Charlie John John Collier
John John Collier yeah I mean you sound
sounds bit sort of boring now it's not
as good as bullet-tooth tony is it you
know can we can do better than this yeah
come on bit you've got beard maybe that
is double stubble face John there you go
that's poo do you know why I do have
once again I have different colored eyes
brilliant all right ones green ones
Brown might blue brown John not bad we
Brown Vivian because that means you will
know if it's a woman or a man aren't
quite like that
alright I'll call over blue brown Vivian
blue Branford and Vivian
blue brown Vivian they dumped myself
now I've got a special bonus Guy Ritchie
clip on challenging yourself but before
that my question of the day I want to
have a little bit of fun with you guys
go back to the last clip rule number ten
and have fun I want to know what your
geezer name would be leave it down the
comments below I'm excited to see what
you have to say thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon and enjoy the bonus clip
I've sort of built up a momentum of
enjoying challenges which previously I
would have found too intimidating and
I've sort built up a bit of directing is
mostly about confidence and I built up
sort of a confidence that oh I don't
know how to do that in genre can I have
a go that genre I don't know how to do
that shawl right can I have a go that
genre and that's really what's happened
because I could you know I I was weaned
on urban London small gangster stuff and
I was comfortable in that world and to
try and get out of that hard and you
know the with the Sherlock what happen
was you someone presented I said because
I was being too fussy about what I was
trying to do I thought hold on my mind's
gang in the way here too much and I said
the next script that turns up on my desk
I'm gonna make it and the next script
that turned up with Sherlock Holmes so I
thought how else this could how much of
a challenges this could provide I did
like Sherlock Holmes as a kid which was
advantageous but it was a completely new
world for me but after I made that I
could see the correlations between that
which I was familiar with and how much
you could do that was unfamiliar but was
exciting and you didn't over stretch and
then I thought after I did that I
thought well why don't we take us to
join into the 60s with Man From UNCLE
and now you know you feel quite
confident there and the well why not now
go back to the 8th century and have a go
at King Arthur so as I say that's really
confidence raise your standard Apple at
the core is core values
is that we move that people your passion
can change the way that not one drop of
myself work depends on your it's suppose
to mean
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten rows of success I have
a very special secret video for you
these are the individual clips that I
have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link in description for
details